you look stunning as always thank you oh
my god like feel like I'm so far away
from the audience
[Laughter]
[Applause]
get out here let's get this done you can
always change your life
it's really nice like a bucket list
thing ya know weird we're gonna have to
get like an a motor or something cuz
right now just yelling at guys to come
out here and push us it feels very like
I'm an Egyptian pharaoh yeah you need
palm fronds yes exactly I just feel like
push push a little bit nice I can see
all your faces and fur nice
[Applause]
if there's anything you want anything at
all I can get it for you Rebecca you
know yeah if you see any jewelry or
anything you like well honey today take
your time you know first of all I want
to ask you because I was just talking or
just just having a discussion with fitty
cent he brought up underwear and he's
got this one hundred and fifty dollar
underwear that he's selling now I know
that you your husband Jerry O'Connell
very frugal man would he ever buy $150
underwear he would never in a million
years by $150 what did you think but
that underwear it looked good sure
yeah I mean it's hundred fifty dollars
yes no he also he mentioned that a women
can spend like a fortune on underwear
what is the high end of what women can
spend on lingerie I mean you know they
make a famous million dollar bra for
Victoria's Secrets I mean it's there
there is what is it do it's got diamonds
on it oh it's got diamonds I thought it
had little drone tell you things that
moved your breasts around and it said
that you know yes and shoot things yeah
[Laughter]
yeah remote control
ymo control yeah I'm going to get I'm
losing reception I'm trying to call my
penis and we're lost it what I want to
do is I'm going to model the underwear
50 cents gonna get it for me I'm going
to model it you don't seem too thrilled
about that is that a picture on the
inside is that a photograph that you
would look at it would you rather not
and you can be totally honest with your
curio yeah all right yeah okay all right
now so I'll just bring the photo to your
house how it works
we're gonna do this just privately
you're gonna show to me what did you
have Gerry to be right you know just you
know you sent him on an errand or
something I'll come by with the picture
look at just show up in the underwear
I'll show up in the Unruh do you really
want that yes no you really don't want
that
you know this skin toned is not you'll
see it's not this is me with makeup this
looks like a Salmons belly down here the
salmon that died like six weeks ago yes
it does yeah I often get calls from
astronauts saying what's going on down
there
you